bonjour patrick le hyaric vous avez
députés européens mais aussi directeur
de l'humanité on l'a dit votre journal a
été le seul quotidien national à
paraître le 26 mai dernier puisqu'il a
été le seul à accepter la parution d'un
communiqué d'un tract de la cgt contre
la loi travail le syndicat a bloqué
l'impression d autres journaux est ce
que vous pensez que cette méthode est
correct est ce que c'est une bonne
méthode
mais pas plus que pour les syndicats des
travailleurs du lift pas plus que ceux
des éboueurs ou de la sncf moi je n'ai
pas à prendre partie je n'ai à prendre
position sur les méthodes d'action
quant à cantat quand je suis pas patron
je suis directeur du journal
comme vous avez vous-même impropre
direct et clair qui était pas non plus
pas trop je l'appelle papa 30
je m'appelle collègues et donc et
choisissent leurs méthodes
quant à la publication du texte de
philippe martinez
il y avait pas de raison que nous ne
publions pas ce texte puisque philippe
martinez il est régulièrement interviewé
dans le journal il a les délégués cgt et
d'autres syndicalistes ont des tribunes
dans le journal donc nous n'avions pas
raison de le refuser vous est aussi
président de l'association pour le
pluralisme de la presse je crois est-ce
que s'il n'ya pas justement une rupture
de ce principe de pluralisme
quand il n'y a qu'un seul quotidien qui
paraît avec les autres sont bloqués ah
si il ya une rupture de pluralisme ce
n'est pas une bonne chose qu'il n'y
avait qu'un seul journal dans les
kiosques
moi je souhaite non pas dix journaux ou
en journaux nationaux dans la coiffe
dans lakers mais gens souhaiteraient 40
plus voilà vous avez dit tout à l'heure
en début d'émission que le rassemblement
du front de gauche si on peut encore
l'appeler comme ça était et est toujours
possible
ça passe par quoi ça passe peut-être par
le soutien des communistes à la
candidature de jean luc mélenchon c'est
envisageable ça ça passe par le travail
qui est engagée ce que j'ai expliqué
tout à l'heure c'est à dire
le parti communiste a décidé de faire
une grande consultation auprès de 500 ou
600 mille personnes sur ce à quoi
aspirent les gens nous en avons bien une
idée mais nous voulons avoir ce débat
avec eux mais ça programmatique pas que
programmatique c'est à dire il peut il
peut y avoir
l'élection à la présidence de la
république moi je pense que un candidat
à la présidence de la république doit
avoir un dessin pour la france mais pas
pour cinq ans plus tôt pour 50 ans la
question des élections législatives
après c'est un programme de législature
et donc il faut avoir une vision
d'avenir du pays et tirer le pays vers
la et le le parti communiste compte fin
du mois de septembre
proposer ce qu'il appelle un pacte
d'engagement commun à partir de cette
consultation la et qui va converger
puisque c'est votre question qui
convergera vraisemblablement avec un
certain nombre de choses que propose
jean luc mélenchon lui même vous fermez
absolument pas la porte un rapprochement
en vue de la présidentielle
avec avec jean luc mélenchon nous le
débat aujourd'hui et le débat cac a
lancé pierre laurent depuis plusieurs
mois il est il est un débat qui porte
sur la question deux pour un candidat de
la transformation sociale de gagner
l'élection présidentielle et de gagner
les élections législatives d'avoir une
autre majorité au parlement
c'est ça le débat est donc tout son
effort et consiste à rechercher les
conditions d'une telle candidature
mais cette candidature peut être jean
luc mélenchon si toutes ces forces qui
aujourd'hui se réclame de bien d'un
changement véritable se réclame vraiment
du côté gauche
et bien si tout l'effort se retrouve
dans la candidature de jean luc
mélenchon alors peut être jean luc
mélenchon il refuse il l'a déjà dit
plusieurs fois le principe de la
primaire à gauche que le pcf lui
soutient ou soutenait en tout cas est ce
que vous pensez que cette primaire elle
a encore ses chances
non le paris blois parti communiste
contrairement à ses traditions et son
histoire début janvier quand s'est posé
la question de la primaire le jour même
le soir même lors de ses voeux pierre
laurent a dit que ce n'était pas sa
culture mais qu'il ouvrait la porte
les choses ont beaucoup changé depuis
aujourd'hui le il a il a avancé l'idée
de créer les conditions peut-être d'une
consultation d'une sorte de votation
citoyenne au mois d'octobre
mais la primaire telle qu'elle était
conçue initialement ne peut pas avoir
lieu
on ne peut pas faire une primaire
aujourd'hui avec des des gens qui font
par exemple la loi de précarisation du
travail
je voulais vous faire réagir à une
petite phrase prononcée par jean
christophe cambadelis lancé la semaine
dernière lors d'une fête de la rose dans
l'yonne il a dit je regarde que le pca
ferme à nouveau la porte de l'unité et
ce qui est encore quelque chose à tirer
de la relation entre le pcf et le parti
socialiste aujourd'hui mais bien sûr ce
sont 2,2 courant d'une dune
une vieille même branche seulement le
problème
il porte sur la question de savoir si on
peut changer la société
vraisemblablement la direction du parti
socialiste je parle du parti socialiste
je ne parle pas du gouvernement à la
direction du parti socialiste ferait
seulement depuis plusieurs années on
pense qu'il faut s'aligner sur le parti
socialiste européen et on considère que
dans le cadre de la mondialisation
actuelle vaut mieux s'adapter
nous nous pensons que dans le cadre de
la mondialisation vaut mieux créer les
conditions d'une transformation sociale
et écologique
sinon nous irons dans le mur nous irons
dans le mur d'un point de vue économique
et sociale es et surtout sur la question
écologique 40 secondes pour justement
sur cette question l'union de la gauche
en 2012 vous étiez désisté au second
tour des législatives en
seine-saint-denis au profit d'elisabeth
guigou qui était mieux placé que vous au
second tour seriez vous prêt à faire la
même chose en 2017 si jamais la
situation se présentait je ne sais pas
quelles sont vos ambitions mais si
jamais
vous seriez vous prêt à vous désister
non je resterai oui parce que la
situation est totalement différente
d'abord je constate que dans une
élection départementale partiel à
allonnes le mans mes amis sont en tête
nous avons fait un ticket écologistes et
mon ami le maire d'allonnes les
candidats socialistes réseau data de
droite ni d'extrême droite à
aubervilliers il n'y en avait pas non
plus à aubervilliers il y en avait pas
non plus mais aujourd'hui dans les
conditions d'aujourd'hui
vu ce que madame la députée vote au
parlement
je n'ai pas de points d'accord et je
resterai vraisemblable